Melissa McCarthy responds to Jennifer
Aniston's Huffington Post op-ed ET spoke
with the Ghostbuster star on the red
carpet at Tuesday's Gilda Radner fest in
NYC where she agreed with Aniston's
impassioned essay about the way society
scrutinizes women's bodies I agree
100,000 and billion percent with that
it's always about how a woman looks I
think he's very interesting he's a good
writer she's looking older than she did
last somebody's her friend didn't give
her everybody I think everybody's stuff
needs to stop tearing down women I just
hope it gets at the point where it's
like embarrassing for people to have
such a shallow thought the 45 year old
mother of two then gushed over how her
daughter's georgette and Vivian helped
their mama with her new fashion line
she's been rocking during her press tour
for Ghostbusters my oldest daughters
made three different prints for me back
in the graffiti she had dropped part of
part of the drawings on my graffiti
printer from her so they're they're very
very much involved and they and you
never are short on the opinions